Congress will decide the fate of much of
the agenda the president laid out last
night and approval is no short thing
Nancy Cordes is on Capitol Hill with the
odds of success for some of the
president's plans Nancy good morning
good morning well immigration is the one
issue that has to be resolved first
everything here on Capitol Hill is
essentially frozen in place until then
the challenges that the president laid
out the four pillars of his immigration
agenda last night and Democrats deeply
opposed two of those pillars the ones
that we spoke to after the speech said
they can accept tougher border security
in exchange for a path to citizenship
for those so-called dreamers young
people brought to this country illegally
as children but Democrats oppose the
president's proposal to end the visa
lottery program and especially to
restrict family based immigration Oregon
Senator Jeff Merkley told us the
president is using dreamers as quote a
right-wing bargaining chip but
Republicans noted that it's going to be
next to impossible to get House
conservatives to go along with this
dreamer plan if it doesn't include tough
new reforms one issue both sides were
hoping to hear more about last night was
opioids the President did have this
emotional moment where he addressed the
drug epidemic by introducing a police
officer and his wife who had adopted a
baby from a victim of heroin addiction
but while President Trump said he was
committed to addressing the problem
members of Congress from both sides
wanted to hear specifics and they didn't
last night John Nancy thanks